[Musique étrangère]
c'est presque comme s'ils se révélaient
comme si vous ne les voyiez pas
quand vous marchez à un rythme,
vous ne pouvez tout simplement pas étudier les lichens à la hâte, il suffit de
prendre votre temps et d'apprécier
les petites choses de la vie
[  Musique]
alors là, vous connaissez cinq ou
six espèces dans cette petite zone et
quand vous volez juste à côté de vous, vous
ne remarquez pas
[Musique]
un lichen est principalement un champignon,
c'est un champignon qui vit un
mode de vie particulier.
travailler avec un
partenaire de photosynthèse, donc la plupart du
temps, ce sera une algue à
l'intérieur de laquelle les algues vivent et ce champignon se construit presque
comme une serre
et il fait pousser cette algue à l'intérieur qui
se photosynthétise et produit de
l'énergie et des sucres, il nourrit le
champignon qu'il est connu sous le nom  l'une des grandes
symbioses du monde, ce sont ces
multiples organismes qui travaillent ensemble
[Musique]
donc le champignon vit généralement dans le bois dans le sol,
il tire son énergie de la chose
dans laquelle il vit et quand il se
lichénise quand il commence à travailler avec un
partenaire de photosynthèse est  une
transformation, il a l'air complètement
différent de ce qu'il est quand ils sont
seuls
vivent sur des rochers ils peuvent vivre sur des arbres ils
peuvent vivre sur du sol sur du ciment sur à peu près
n'importe quoi dans le monde terrestre
étranger
ils n'ont pas de racines à peu près tous
Botanique  l'organisme extrait des choses
du sol, ce qui n'est pas le cas, comme les
lichens sont un organisme vraiment spécial
de cette façon
et c'est ce qui les rend si sensibles que les
lichens sont comme des canaris dans la
mine de charbon parce qu'ils mangent l'air
essentiellement ils obtiennent leurs
nutriments directement de  la pluie et
de l'air s'il y a quelque chose dans l'
air,
ils le sentiront d'abord, donc les
lichens sont très sensibles à la pollution de l'air,
voici l'un des lichens
que j'espérais signaler et trouver
aujourd'hui c'est le lichen de la carte jaune  c'est
ce jaune verdâtre c'est particulièrement
commun dans les endroits plus exposés comme celui-ci
nous sommes au bord de l'escarpement de
ces roches exposées c'est aussi très
commun dans l'Arctique
le plus vieux lichen que nous connaissons est
celui-ci
et il a été âgé d'environ  8 600 ans
[Musique]
beaucoup d'animaux mangent des lichens si je peux
les utiliser comme matériel de nidification je peux les utiliser
car il y a beaucoup d'insectes qui se sont
camouflés pour ressembler à des lichens
d'innombrables ongulés ont été vus
manger des lichens le cas le plus célèbre  est le
caribou, ils dépendent des lichens en
hiver comme c'est leur principale source de nourriture
pendant les mois d'hiver
vous réalisez que vous pouvez commencer à
apprécier la quantité de biodiversité,
vous pouvez également apprécier quand vous
savez à quel point ils grandissent lentement
et à quel point ils peuvent être importants
pour moi, ils sont essentiels pour comprendre les
mondes naturels, ils sont importants pour
aider à le comprendre et  protégez-le
et gérez-le,
nous avons été très doués pour accorder beaucoup d'
attention aux espèces charismatiques d'
arbres et à la grande mégafaune charismatique, mais
je veux dire que toute vie a une valeur intrinsèque
et toute vie a des rôles importants et
sans doute les petites choses
qui sont dans l'écologie  monde sont les
choses qui sont les moteurs
comme conduire l'ensemble du système et
ils sont tout aussi importants il n'y a
aucune raison pour laquelle nous ne devrions pas
accorder autant d'attention aux petites
choses que nous faisons les plus grandes choses
qu'ils effectuent toujours un  fonction et
il est important pour nous d'étudier les lichens
à ce stade car il y a de grands
changements qui se produisent en ce moment et vous ne pouvez pas
reconnaître le changement que vous connaissez sans
une ligne de base, nous avons ces lignes de basse changeantes
sur les espèces où se trouvent
une crise de la biodiversité
dans le monde en ce moment et il y a un
exemple juste là et sans
sortir et les étudier et apprendre et
comprendre ces écosystèmes rares et
les espèces qui en dépendent, vous risquez de
perdre des espèces que nous ne connaissons jamais et qui
sait quel type de produits chimiques ils pourraient
des produits qui pourraient être utilisés par les humains pour
guérir qui sait quoi, mais en réalité, cela
devrait simplement se résumer à la
valeur intrinsèque qu'ils sont une forme de vie et que toutes les
formes de vie ont une valeur
étrangère